quel titre provocateur quel titre de
vidéos provocateur vous inquiétez pas ça
va bien se passer
on va parler du coco on je dis pas le
mot parce que youtube démonétise qu'est
ce que je voulais vous dire ça fait
longtemps déjà qu'on s'est pas vu là ça
fait longtemps
alors vous voyez je suis encore dans un
autre environnement j'ai déménagé mais
c'est pas chez moi je suis à l'hôtel là
pendant deux semaines
autant vous dire que c'est le pire
endroit dans cette crise de coco ah bah
oui c'est un endroit où les gens
voyagent beaucoup ils viennent ils
partent et c'est partout dans le monde
donc voilà je suis à peu près sûr
sérieusement sans van que je vais te
choper géré il ya de très fortes chances
mais ça m'inquiète pas plus que ça
déjà quand on regarde les stats de
létalité assez peu de chance finalement
que voilà ça me
ça me tue puisque je n'ai que 12 ans
donc au final mais vous aussi il est
possible que vous l'ayez et vous en
rendiez même pas compte parce qu'il ya
80% des gens pour qui ces
asymptomatiques alors ce chiffre il
vient de 44 1600 cas qui ont été
étudiées par le chinese center of
control dix épreuves et en gros il ya à
peu près 80% des cas qui sont
asymptomatiques ce qui est une bonne
nouvelle
il ya un autre élément pour nous
rassurer souci de voir comment on réagit
au virus serre que quand on regarde
comment on a réagi pour h1n1 par exemple
oui mais voilà on a eu des réactions de
pays d etat des gouvernements qui était
beaucoup plus forte
donc ils ont beaucoup mieux et réagit
entre guillemets parce que c'était
beaucoup plus mortel et donc dangereux
après j'ai mis des guillemets à mieux
parce que c'est pas parce qu'on réagit
plus fort que c'est forcément mieux
mieux réagir c'est réagir en concordance
avec la menace de mettre de manière
proportionnelle à jeudi au chaos
concordantes
aucun sens dans cette phrase parce qu'on
pourrait dire ok il a ses shows paf on
ferme les frontières on ferme les vols
dès qu'il ya un cas bîmes dans l'oise
par exemple pape la quarantaine on
bloque les gens et on pourrait faire ça
et c'est ce que la chine a fait
d'ailleurs à la mis un peu de temps mais
très vite elle a créé des grosses zones
de quarantaine
mais il ya un petit problème avec la
quarantaine c'est que elle crée ce qu'on
appelle en économie un choc d'offre
en gros il y à une baisse de la
production parce que les travailleurs
ils sont confinés tout simplement
généralement pour relancer l'économie on
stimule la demande c'est la technique
qu'on utilise le plus fréquemment ce qu
en fait stimulé la demande ça n'a aucun
sens avec un choc d'offre
ça ne règle pas ce problème de choc
d'offre donc en fait on fait des
quarantaines pour sauver des vies mais
il ya un vrai coût économique et en
économie bas le coût de la vie il n'est
pas illimité quoi c'est un peu dur à
dire c'est en économie et en je pense
qu'en philosophie aussi on peut se poser
la question
2 c'est quoi le coup d'une vie et ça
pourrait faire le sujet d'une super
vidéo je pense
mais en économie on peut pas partir du
principe que une vie c'est illimité on
fait plein de fois des arbitrages avec
le coût de la vie par exemple quand on
fait le code de la route ou quand on
crée d'énormes par rapport à des
produits dangereux et c'est à chaque
fois on est obligé de dire ok bon bah le
coût de la vie on va lui donner temps et
on va faire les normes en fonction
parce que si on donne un coût de la vie
illimitée autant vous dire que sur les
autoroutes
on roule tous à 30 parce qu'on est sur
quatre ans il n'y a pas d'accident donc
c'est pas toujours le truc le plus
important une crise économique comme
celle de 2008
elle peut faire énormément de dégâts et
donc c'est quelque chose qu'on veut
éviter la jemaye deux courbes de
comparaison entre la crise qu en train
de se préparer là maintenant et celle de
2008 est clairement ça fait un peu
flipper ce que ce que ce virus est en
train de créer c'est violent pour nos
organismes et c'est violent parce que le
pourcentage de la population qui risque
de mourir mais c'est en train de créer
une crise en fait potentiellement je
peux en train de dire que c'est moins
grave ou plus grave etc
mais je dis que voilà il ya des
questions qui se posent et c'est pour ça
que les
dirigeants sont pas en mode on ferme
tout et sait notamment que ces questions
là d'où le titre de la vidéo et ce qu'il
faut sauver tout le monde mais en vrai
je comprends cette psychose le terme
psychose me dérange un petit peu ce que
psycho c'est assez fort c'est une
maladie mentale
à la base c'est c'est un film aussi
qu'elle a vraiment très bien
j'ai pas vu je tirais surtout forte
anxiété voilà sept ans que c'était je la
comprends quand on regarde les symptômes
un des premiers symptômes ce genre là
toute sèche quoi la toute fin je veux
dire si on doit s'inquiéter des comptes
où ce n'est pas dans la mouise
le truc inquiétant ce que comme je vous
disais au début de la vidéo il ya 80%
des cas qui sont asymptomatiques
en tout cas selon cette étude c'est
aussi une mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'en
fait il ya plein de gens qui l'ont et
qui vont pas s'en rendre compte et qui
n'ont pas faire attention surtout à leur
comportement vis-à-vis des autres et
donc ils vont mettre en danger d'autres
personnes donc ça s'est il permis étant
aussi donc je peux comprendre cette
anxiété et moi le premier je suis en
flip
je me suis posé la question devait ce
qu'il fallait que je fasse un stock de
pâtes etc
enfin voila je peux comprendre 12 et
surtout que les réseaux sociaux nous est
pas du tout sur les réseaux sociaux les
messages qui ressorte ça va pas être des
messages nuancé ça va être des messages
de type mec c'est pas plus grave qu'une
grippe qu'elle me toi et donc les gens
soient là j'aurais well as raison mais
il faut se calmer macha et l'autre côté
on a des gens qui sont là en mode
ouais c'est la fin du monde fait des
stocks fait des provisions moi je vous
offrirai pas la porte quand il y aura
plus de pâtes et les besoins que les
deux sont un peu fou quoi ça que c'est
un peu plus dangereux qu'une grippe on
va pas se mentir
et y'a pas de quoi faire un stock de
pâtes surtout que c'est parce que les
gens font des stocks de pâtes ou du riz
ou de ce que vous voulez que la pénurie
secret genre par exemple en australie et
à une pénurie de pq les australiens ils
sont dix olala faut que j'assure mes
arrières niveau toilettes là encore ça
aurait été une épidémie de gastro
j'aurais compris mais je comprends pas à
quoi sauf si ils ont un usage du pq très
différent du nôtre et que je sais pas si
vous êtes australien
australienne dites moi mais c'est vrai
que ces réseaux sociaux de façon il nous
aide pas en terme de
pas de stress et d'anxiété appelé sa
psychose si vous voulez je vous donner
quelques chiffres permettent de mettre
en perspective cet impact des réseaux
sociaux par rapport aux autres épidémies
qu'on a eue sur les dix dernières années
donc en 2003 on avait le sar ce qu'ils
avaient un taux de létalité de 10% en
2009 on avait h1n1 je vois 4 5% en 2014
on avait ebola 25% qui a tué onze mille
personnes nouveau en 2020 on a le coco
2% qui a tué 38 personnes en 78 jours
donc là on se rend compte que le coco
c'est le moins dangereux entre
guillemets a priori a priori parce que
évidemment toute cette vidéo tout ce que
je dis là c'est là maintenant à un
instant t
je crois qu'on est on est le 7 mars
voilà le virus peut muter il peut se
passer d'autres choses
voilà mais là à l'instant t c'est par
rapport à la liste que je vous ai dit
c'est un des moins dangereux mais si on
met en perspective ça par rapport à
d'autres chiffres ça nous permet de nous
rendre compte de l'impact des réseaux
sociaux par exemple donc en 2003 donc
pendant sarsiat veni facebook nehoua
tape ça n'existait pas encore en 2009
pendant h1n1 facebook n'avait que 130
millions d'utilisateurs en 2014 durant
ebola whatsapp avec 450 millions
d'utilisateurs et là en 2020 whatsapp
ils ont 2 milliards d'utilisateurs et
facebook
1 27 milliard donc c'est énorme la place
compris les réseaux sociaux dans nos
vies en quelques années et donc
forcément ça joue sur notre appréhension
des épidémies ça nous enclins à être
plus flipper et donc créer plus
facilement des pénuries
mais aussi créer plus facilement une
crise économique potentiel qui peut
avoir des conséquences dramatiques
mais voilà en tout cas moi je suis assez
d'accord avec un professeur en
épidémiologie epide
et puis 10 et wall épidémiologie donc
j'ai assez d'accord avec marc lipsitch
un professeur en épidémiologie à harvard
qui dit que ça va être juste une maladie
qui va se rajouter à d'autres maladies
qu'on ne connaît déjà genre au lieu
d'avoir la saison de la grippe
il va y avoir la saison de la grippe et
du coco et d'ailleurs c'est pas le seul
et puis des biologistes
j'ai réussi du premier coup à le dire il
ya plein d'autres
apparemment ça fait consensus d'après un
article de tes atlantiques
voilà j'essaie de citer ses sources un
maximum pour que vous ayez le plus
d'informations possible et c'est marrant
parce que je voudrais parler sur
instagram j'ai demandé aussi oublier que
je traite le sujet d'une certaine
manière vous étiez beaucoup à me parler
du traitement de l'épidémie par les
médias et je vous avoue je vais être
très honnête je le connais assez mal
parce que j'ai pas l'impression que pour
sauver mon info via les médias
traditionnels genre souvent en bas par
exemple sur twitter je vais et sert à
trouver un spécialiste qui fait un trade
avec plein de data avec des études et c
est très tôt en fait sur cette crise
j'ai eu mes infos via ça je peux vous
mettre des liens d'ailleurs dans la
description des threads qui peuvent être
intéressants sur le sujet mais je pense
que l'information pure c'est la clé
contre 1 la panique et 2 juste
l'ignorance et dire que il se passe rien
du tout c'est pas grave etc
non il ya une forme enfin faut prendre
les choses au sérieux ne faut pas
paniquer non plus fort voilà comme
souvent à notre époque
je trouve que autour de nous ça manque
un peu de nuance
donc voilà j'espère que j'ai réussi à
porter ça avec cette vidéo que je trouve
ça intéressant quand même de vous
partager quelques trucs que j'ai trouvé
cool que j'ai lu d'intéressant ou que
j'ai pensé de bien sûr sur le coco joue
très vite pour une prochaine vidéo gros
bisous love peace et spray anti
bactérien